much for the opportunity to talk so
today I'm going to talk a little bit
about more general title systematic
functional notation of large-scale
biological networks so as we all know
people in this room in the last decade
or so as a field we have accumulated a
huge amount of a very large number of
biological networks this networks map
all sorts of relationship between genes
and over the years as we have been
accumulating this data we learned pretty
well how to interpret the data we were
acquiring based on the level of
individual interactions at least we have
a very good understanding what for
example a physical binding means we have
a pretty good understanding what
protein-dna interactions means we also
in some cases were figure out how to
interpret local structure and modules
within networks we know that if a group
of proteins all have interaction
physical interactions between them
they're very likely to represent a
protein complex on the other side
however we have a much worse
understanding of what this networks mean
biologically on the global scale and
what's their global organization in
other words we actually have trouble
understanding what have we learned from
mapping all possible interactions of a
given type that is not just given by the
sum of the individual interaction we
have collected what have we learned from
the about the system that this network
represent and many of the networks are
genome scale so they do represent the
entire system the entire cell they were
derived from what have we learned from
mapping all of them all of these
interactions rather than a subset of
them or each of them individually so
this is a very hard problem and it's
definitely not going to be solved in a
year or two but today I wanted to talk
about some of the steps that I'm taking
in order to address that question and as
an example for the methods that have
been developing I'm going to use this
network in particular as as a test case
because I'm very familiar with this
network this network is a genetic
interaction similarity network that was
produced about six years ago and on this
network every node represented gene and
two genes are connected by an edge if
their genetic interaction profiles are
similar more similar than its chosen
threshold so before i go into explaining
how we are addressing how we are looking
into this network i have to explain it
please make sure we are on the same page
in terms of what a genetic interaction
is and what does it mean why is it
important for two genes to have similar
genetic interaction profiles so we have
heard a little bit about it earlier
today so genetic interactions represent
a phenotypic relationship between genes
and they happen when a double mutant has
an unexpected phenotype based on the two
singles that you started from a
classical example is synthetic lethality
you have two single mutants that could
probably be very very similar to wild
type but then the double mutant is
unexpected unexpectedly sick or even
lethal we usually interpret this many
cases could be explained by a simple
parallel pathway model you have two
pathways that impinge on the same
essential biological function such that
you can get rid of either one a member
of either one of the two branches and
nothing will happen but if you create a
double mutation then the function cannot
be completed anymore in the cell is dead
another example is what some people
refer it as epistasis is a very
confusing term but it all it indicates
is that you have you might have two
single mutants that both have some sort
of phenotype and then the double mutant
is the same has the same phenotype this
is still unexpected because one way or
another you expected the phenotypes of
the two single mutants to combine and be
for example the growth should be worse
than either one of them individually
some of the cases that behave like this
can be explained by a linear pathway
model here you have a single path linear
pathways that impinges on a non
essential function and when you delete a
member of this path where you block in
the entire pathway completely so adding
secondary mutations in the same process
will not really make it any worse of
course this is an extreme
oversimplification of the situation
there is the many more cases that don't
fit into either one of these two
categories in fact it's a spectrum of
events and we and others have learned
over the years that one easy way to kind
of quantify and look at this all is to
measure a score for any given double
mutant that's given by the difference
between the double mutant phenotype and
the product of the two singles the
product here is just a convention to
indicate what phenotype you would have
expected if the two single mutants were
independent there is a bunch of
different models that will predict what
expectation is this is just one of them
there is really no systematic analysis
to figure out which one is the batter
but this one has been working pretty
well and based on this simple approach
you can categorize this interactions as
a negative because in the double mutant
is much lower the phenotype of the
double mutant is much lower than you
expected and these guys is positive
because it will be much higher so as you
can imagine knowing obtaining this
information is very valuable for
understanding what the relationship
between genes and a decade-long more
than a decade long project in Toronto is
aiming at constructing and analyzing all
possible combinations of double mutants
in a single model organism which is
yeast and ceased has six thousand genes
so there is a total of 36 million
combinations and I'm going to talk to
about today some of the work we've done
if up to a few years ago and also if I
have time a little update on where we
are now and the short version is that
the project is almost complete so once
we and others have started collecting
this data on a systematic scale on a
large scale people realize that not only
individual interactions who are
informative but also knowing that two
genes share main interactions in common
of the same type was extremely
informative about their relationships if
member we found out that members of the
same protein complex for example will
have a very high correlation between
their genetic interaction profiles that
are defined just as a set of
interactions between a gene and all the
other genes in the genome of course with
data like this clustering made
matrices and clustering have been
applied very early on but once the data
starts growing clustering becomes very
very impractical both because it's just
a huge matrix to deal with and also
because it becomes more and more
difficult to find interesting trends in
this giant matrix so one approach that
we have board actually from a
neighboring field is to represent the
same data as networks so basically what
you're doing is you're taking all of the
data from this data set computing
pairwise correlations between every pair
of jeans that you have and representing
them as a network where nodes at jeans
and two genes are connected by an edge
that's weighted based on the correlation
of their profiles this is very similar
to coexpression networks for example the
only difference is what data goes into
their correlation and then you can take
this network and apply a network layout
to it then I'm going to get back to in a
second in particular a class of network
layouts they're called force-directed
that will reorganize the network in
two-dimensional space such that tightly
connected nodes will be close to each
other in 2d and the guys that are not so
tightly connected will be free to move
and eventually will be pushed away at
the end of the day so network layouts
have been around for quite some time but
surprisingly they've been used mostly
for presenting networks were creating
visualizations however if you think
about it the computing the correlation
part and the layout part I effectively
multidimensionality reductions
approaches right you're taking a gene
from a very high dimensional space and
placing it on in 2d space relative to
all the other genes in the genome or in
your data set in a way that makes sense
it's completely data-driven so when we
applied this idea to the entire network
back back in 2010 we that's the network
way god once again jeans here a node are
represented represent jeans and two
genes are connected by an edge if their
profiles genetic interaction profiles
have a Pearson correlation greater than
point to where both Pearson correlation
endpoints you are completely arbitrary
choices so I will get back to that if I
have time
so obviously the first time we saw this
this we thought it was very interesting
because as you can see genes are not
randomly distributed throughout this
network they form this very large groups
or clusters if you if you can want to
call them that are much very densely
connected and a clearly much bigger than
complexes or pathways that we knew were
that we expected from this data so we
went in a lot of trouble trying to
annotate this network yeah
so there was one giant connected
component which is this one and probably
maybe 20 more disconnected which
probably are driven by the the cat
applied cut off yeah yeah you can dial
it up or down depending on your
computational power how much your
computer can handle in terms of
representation yeah that's what yeah
that's what that's what the point 2
comes from that's at the time that's
what my computer could handle but of
course I mean it's definitely the way to
go is to make whatever every analysis
independent from that cut off or as
independent as possible yeah in actually
so I have data suggesting that the
analysis that I am going to present is
fairly insensitive insensitive to the
specifics of the cut off within a
certain range okay so we we went into a
lot of trouble trying to understand what
this the giant clusters on this network
represent and we did a very complex
analysis based on some clustering but
mostly manual investigation of the
network in other words we zoomed in in
particular regions look at the genes and
try to assign a label to them that made
sense based on what we knew about the
jeans it's a very kind of thorough but
extremely long and time-consuming
procedure that took about probably
several weeks to accomplish well they're
the good news that when we finished was
that we could assign a label and were
very confident about the functional
association of every region of the
network with a particular biological
function so for example this this region
was clearly enriched for secretion and
vesicle mediated transport genes this
region over there was clearly DNA
replication and repair right so the data
that was roughly what we expected but at
the same time was interesting to see
that it actually true so since then
obviously so this has been six years ago
the Toronto team has been kept screen
and obviously and produced a large
amount of data that unfortunately I
don't have too much time to go into but
the end point of that is that from a
network
this big in 2010 in 2016 we had a
network that was largely 50 times larger
and in reality was composed from two
independent networks drived
independently experimentally one that
was composed entirely of non-essential
genes and the other one that was
entirely essential and then the combined
network is the one that was much bigger
corresponding to the one we had before
so because we basically obtained three
network three new networks and all of
them were larger than the original that
we started from when the the question
was asked okay so what what are these
networks what's new about them with
respect to the old one it was a
completely unfeasible to redo the same
analysis we did last time because it
would just take forever and would not be
reproducible and just not the way to do
it so the what became apparent is that
we need an automated and unbiased way to
perform the same operation basically to
answer the question of what is what on
this network what functions are
represented where are they how they're
related to the previous version of the
network how they're related in the two
different parts of this network to
answer all these questions in an
unbiased and systematic and hopefully
quantitative way and so that was part of
my job as part of as a member of the
team and what I came up with in a sim
very simple idea thats actually builds
on many of the discoveries and research
of many people in this room but it
worked extremely well for the kind of
questions we had and this so this method
that we came up with we call it spatial
analysis of functional enrichment or
save for short it's based on the idea
that you can take any energy in any node
in that Network and define a local
neighborhood around it local
neighborhood all it means is a set of
the other nodes that are located closer
than a certain distance so of course as
we heard earlier today as well there's
many many different ways to measure
distance in both shortest path length or
some may be no decay functions that can
exponential decay function that can be
used to give different weights to nodes
as you move further and further from
them but one option that we have
considered was to take
to advantage of the layout algorithm
that we have employed to make the
network and we measured distance between
nodes based on the physical length of
their edges once the layout has been
applied so in this case all genes all
the nodes be labeled here are part of
AIDS neighborhood because the sum of the
edges that you have to cross to get from
a to the node is less than a certain
threshold that we have chosen once we
have defined the neighborhood around a
we can run simple functional enrichment
on it for example we can run a hyper
geometric test against any given go term
take the p value that is derived from
that analysis and assign it back to the
node we started from yeah in order to be
able to apply this you have to have a
rough idea that your netid is robust
when one run after another yes yes yeah
yeah we validate so we we did it in
reverse we first applied it on the one
network we had once we got the result we
went back and made sure it was robust
too many independent runs yeah questions
compared to the 2010 network 2016
Network preserves the general futures
similar genes appear in the same place
uh sure respect to insertion of more in
the whole sandwich um so I don't have a
number to tell of obviously if you add
more data things some things were going
to change but they will show at the end
that even I would say that roughly
nothing really major changes we will get
back to this it's easier when when we
when I explain the process okay so as I
said so you take the p value for any
given go term assigning back to the
original a node and then move on to the
next node and you repeat this operation
for every node in the network and at the
end what you have is a set of p values
assigned to every node in the network
that indicates how much did that nodes
neighborhood is in which forgiven go
turn so I've done this for all four
thousand go terms associated with at
least one his gene and what I found is
that there's a quite a
a difference in how go terms behave
across this network there's about twelve
percent of go terms that look like this
so here I'm represented this is the same
network so it's basically a
representation of the same network
except that I'm not showing the edges
but the node positions are exactly the
same and they're each node has an
opacity that's proportional to the
negative log 10 of the p value for this
particular term so what it says is that
this region and this region only is
enriched for ER to golgi vesicles a
transport and there is no other region
on the network that with these
parameters shows that same enrichment
and twelve percent of go terms should
behave like this there is another four
percent of go terms they behave
similarly but now they enrich the
multiple places we call the
multi-regional there is a relationship
between these guys and these guys in the
sense that this tent do tend to be
larger in the number of genes annotated
to them but it's not a very clear
distinction so size is not the only
thing that drives this difference
there's many very large go term that
look like this and maybe fairly small go
terms that look like that that is an
interesting feature that if i have time
i can go back i can go back and discuss
and then the i guess the most
interesting thing was that actually the
vast majority of go terms didn't show
any signal at all so they were either
too small to be represented on this
network or they are represented but they
just don't concentrate in any particular
way i'm not trying to say that this the
go terms are bad i'm just saying in my
interpretation this means that these go
terms do not agree with this network
that means that the way these go terms
group genes is not the same way the
network groups genes yeah the biological
explanation because you are you're
asking for in effect a genetic effect on
cell growth right if you have not affect
directly to the growth absolutely this
is so it's completely network driven
whatever the network is if the network
doesn't capture certain phenotypic
certain biological processes they will
not be represented here it's completely
the network driven okay but so the good
news is that if i take this twelve
percent of go terms all together cover
all of the multi-regional terms
there is at least one go term that is
represented in a region that it's
enriched for at least one multi-regional
terms so for this for the rest of their
analysis I'm going to ignore these guys
all together I'm only going to focus on
this twelve percent which is about five
hundred go terms the other thing to
consider obviously is that go terms are
not perfectly separate from each other
there there's a huge amount of
redundancy especially parent and child
right so we can measure that redundancy
in terms of similarity of their
enrichment landscapes which is this set
of enrichment that you see in the
network so this guy and this guy even if
they are not identical but they enriched
in the same region and we can measure
that this guy is different from this guy
because obviously they enriched in
different regions so what we can do to
try to summarize this all together and
so that you don't have to look at 500 of
these plots is we can assign the same
color to these two because they're
similar but different colors to this too
and then we can sum them all up
basically compile them together into a
single map that will just for every node
will have a color that is the sum of all
the other colors that is proportional to
their relative enrichment so if a node
is more enriched for a node can be
reached for more than one actually most
terms a most good most nodes iron-rich
for more than one go term but they might
be enriched more for one than the other
so that that goal terms color will be
prevalent so that's when we do this we
can create a combined enrichment
landscape and this is what it looks like
when you do it on this real network so
here every so this again gain that's the
same network as that I'm not showing the
edges but the node position is perfectly
preserved every color corresponds to a
group of go terms enriched in that
region and there's about 19 regions here
and going from here to here takes about
20 seconds compared two weeks that we
used to do before obviously the one part
the machine is not very good at is
actually telling you what the regions
correspond to obviously every region has
a long list of go terms associated with
it but if you just want a glance it
turns out if you just grab the if you
take the go terms names and chop them
into words
and then take the five words that come
up more often that's good enough it's
it's pretty rough but let's say this
group is the five words a transport
membrane protein Golgi localization it's
not perfect but it's good enough to tell
you what's going on okay so in just in
the interest of time I don't have a lot
of space to show you the validation
we've done but we can we know that it's
very accurate it identifies all the
regions we identified in the manual
analysis plus three more tiny little
regions so not surprisingly miss them
before but still it shows you that you
we can be more thorough now it is robust
to numerous sources of variation but
most importantly which to me is the most
important feature is that it's fast and
it's completely automated there's very
little human intervention there and that
means that you can use take the same
network and annotate it with many
different independent functional
standards not just go because we know go
is not far from perfect in many
situations and the first thing that came
to mind is that yeast unlike any other
organism on earth has been studied in
many many different contexts through
thousands of phenotypic screens the
deletion collection has been subjected
to many different stresses and many
different phenotypes have been measured
in particular many chemical genomic
screens have been done and the beauty of
chemical genomics is that they they can
help you understand what the target of a
particular drug is by looking at what
mutants in yeast show particular
sensitivity so drugs in the
oversimplification of the process
sometimes can mimic the phenotypes of
the mutated target which means that if
you have a chemical compound and you
know which genes show particular
sensitivity to it you can guess what the
chemical compound targets because these
genes are likely to be synthetic lethal
with the drugs target so that is very
useful when you don't know what the drug
does because you can look at these genes
try to come up with the idea what their
function they are associated with and
then try to guess what the drug does so
as a test case and to test this with
safe I took one of the most recent
chemical genomics data sets in yeast
that has as a subset of their data 132
chemical genomics screens for drug with
known modes of action so there are no
surprise
there I knew exactly what to expect so
safe had to be modified a little bit so
now instead of just counting how many
neighbors belong to a go term we have
their quantitative values associated and
we can sum them up and then run let's
say thousand over 10,000 Network
randomizations and ask how often does
this neighborhood get this score this
high or they slow in a random situation
and then get an empirical p value out of
that so here is a few examples how that
works so this is the goal based
annotation just for reference this is
the same the outlines are only shown for
the regions that correspond to go terms
and this is a profile for doxorubicin
which is a DNA in Turkey later that
blogs replication and in fact the safe
shows that only one region the region
associated with DNA replication and
repair she is specifically in which for
sensitive Newton's this works only one
also when the drug has more than one
target as is the case for the recurrent
a it has one important function and
inhibits protein synthesis and in fact
we see that the ribosome cluster is
particularly sensitive but it has
another second described function that
is it somehow toxic to mitochondria it's
not very clear why but it there's a
paper in the 80s I first thought it was
a novel finding but then I found the
paper so the way it shows that toxicity
to mitochondria and in fact safe shows
that the regional enriched for
mitochondrial function is also sensitive
but the cool thing is that obviously
even within the known drugs you can find
novel biology as well so here's a
typical case of things you can find with
this method so boot as a map is a known
chemical compound actually is FDA
approved foot of it's an anti-cancer
drug and the save profile showed that
three in particular three major regions
were in which for sensitivity
transcriptional regulation assembly of
the proteome obviously and a cell cycle
regulation so bortezomib is a protozoan
inhibitor so this makes sense it is it
is sin synergistic with age dark
inhibitors so this makes sense and it is
not people think that it's an
anti-cancer drug because it prevents the
degradation
of pro-apoptotic factors so in a way it
and promotes programmed cell death so
probably the cell cycle regulation also
make sense what didn't make sense is
this thing over here so this says that
members of so the Golgi the vesicle
mediated transport function actually
mediates resistance to the drug and as
far as i could think search through the
literature i could not find any
indication of why that would happen
nobody ever described anything like this
so the only link that i could find is
that maybe by inactivating the
proteasome it increases the accumulation
of misfolded proteins in the cell and
they are located in the ER and maybe
that causes ER stress but why would
mutating an ERG in for example make it
better I don't know so that was a
mystery to me the only thing that I
could think of is what if this is
actually has nothing to do with the the
action of bortezomib what if it is a
side effect right it's just the chemical
treatment who knows it's an off-target
effect so the most direct way to test
this was to say well and this is what I
think is happening so i have i have
brought as MIDI inhibiting the protozoan
and when I mean when I and that blocks a
certain pathway but then when I mutate
vesicle media to transport i unblock
another pathway and make it better then
I should be able to recapitulate this
exactly by not treating the sailboat
azmuth by by mutating the pradas produce
them directly right I can create a
double mutant in the bosom gene and the
vesicle mediated jeans and this should
be better than either one of them
individually so that should be a
positive interaction I was lucky because
I actually had all that data already I
didn't have to do an experiment and what
I did is I took the genetic interaction
data for many members of the proteasome
in particular this one guy which is our
PT for is a member of the ad pas of the
in a TPS that's a member of pluralism
and i found that its enrichment profile
is a remarkably similar to the boat as a
map so that means including this part
right so this confirms that this thing
that we see over here is a direct effect
of the boot azimuth inhibiting the
protozoan began
I can recapitulate it exactly using a
mutation so just to summarize what I've
shown you this that we have a method
that it's automated and systematic for
annotating biological network it answers
as of today three major questions I any
regions of the network enriched or
specifically associated with a
particular function or a phenotype we're
in the network this region is and how
does this region compared to other
regions or other functions it builds a
functional map of the network and allows
you to integrate multiple data sets
together I think I don't have any more
time to go through enemy is that okay
yeah so I I will skip to their knowledge
Minh did the rest was just to show how
we have applied this to the new network
so this work was actually everything
except for the experimental data was
done in princeton in my lab I you know
of course many people undergrads and
technicians to think the University of
Toronto of course is providing all the
data we have a long long-term
collaboration with Chad Myers in
Minnesota and I should mention
everything I told you so far there is a
manuscript of button by archive that
describes all of it there is all of the
code written the MATLAB is on bitbucket
there's a link from the manuscript and
we also put together a mac OS standalone
application doesn't require my club and
we're developing a site escape app which
i think is cool anyway that's it thank
you know you deal with multiple
hypothesis testing here yes in the gold
terms because they're nested but also in
the network because the neighbors of
course will have highly correlated
significant we could discuss on fine but
the short answer is that we deal with
multiple testing across go terms because
every neighborhood is tested of course
for 4000 go terms so that p-value is
corrected we're very strange reuse the
bonferroni correction right so every
p-value is divided by the x 4000 right
or multiply it actually x 4000 in terms
of multiple testing across the nodes we
we do at least one thing which is we
ask we filter by how many neighborhoods
enriched in the same for the same go
term but whether or not that actually
addresses the concern of multiple
testing across the nodes because they
overlap I would be happy to discuss that
am I thinking it should address it but I
might have missed something so have you
applied to other side
well I can apply to any network so if
the network exists then yes right if the
network doesn't exist then I can do it
like the genetic interaction network
exists only for one strain but I did
apply skip this but I did apply to a
protein-protein interaction network and
it does work yeah yeah oh yeah Martin do
you treat all the gold turns in the same
way or do you have a difference of
depending on the air key or day ya know
they're they're absolutely agnostic to
the size and the hierarchy of the go
term so they all in it's a bag of terms
right when we start what we did do is
once we have seen the difference between
region-specific multi-regional and spars
we see if how they behave in the
hierarchy the thing is it's not there's
no real correlation no so you would
think that the parent would be
multi-regional and in some case there is
right in the case that I showed you a
protein localization is multi-regional
and localization to they are is
region-specific right make sense but
there are many other examples there's
one famous one with mitochondria where
we see a one might uh I guess it's the
reverse so we see all mitochondrial go
terms in Rio there region-specific they
are all in the same region but if you
look at go they are their common
ancestor is the root right they're not
closer to each other then basically any
random go term and I think that reflects
just how go was constructed this this
mitochondrial terms are biogenesis of
mitochondria energy production and
transport to mitochondria according to
go there as far as they can get
according to our data they're very close
so it can go both ways but it's a very
interesting thing yeah sorry so I get
the rationale for visualization to do it
to the embedding of your network but is
there another reason why why in an
wedding rather than just working with
the graph directly and white two
dimensions yeah and this is an
interesting question it goes so where
should I start so this we started this
from the idea like we wanted to look at
the data so it wasn't motivated by
visualization it evolved into a more
rigorous method today because we realize
how powerful that could be right if you
take into account all the subjectivity
of visualization right for example if
the method is quantitative if you have
multiple testing correction it does
become a true rigorous method and delay
of the embedding as I said at the
beginning is not just for visualization
it could be used for real data analysis
right it's it's driven by the data the
the visualization reflects the topology
of the network is if handled
appropriately so I think my personal
opinion is that this can be a very
powerful rigorous method and it's not
just for visualization but the
visualization adds an aspect to it that
means that i can talk to biologists and
they will understand what I'm saying
anyway sorry for the yeah boy there's
another question so the dozens of them
ready algorithm yes yeah so this one was
completely basically what was available
in cytoscape we tried a bunch and this
was the best we are working right now
and now that we've realized that this
could be this powerful we actually
developing our own algorithms that will
will take all of the information with
things should be included but yeah
definitely there's a bunch of already
existing and we can develop more yeah I
think we'll have to take the rest of
these offline